all right well it happened adult film
actor stormy Daniels was interviewed for
a while I think it was about a half-hour
on CBS's 60 minutes last night we
actually didn't really learn much of
anything new the highlights sort of were
that right after she had spanked Trump
with a rolled-up magazine and I guess
had a sexual encounter with him Trump
said gleefully that she reminds him of
his daughter Ivanka we've that continues
to be really weird and creepy creepy but
we already knew about that she said she
was not physically attracted to Trump
but that she was not a victim this is
not a me-too moment everything that
happened was consensual
she restated that she had been
physically threatened over the affair
she gave the details I believe this part
was new that she was in a Las Vegas
garage on the way to a fitness class and
a guy came up to her she was with her
then infant daughter and said forget
about the Trump story that's a nice
little girl you have would be terrible
if something happened to her mom she was
asked do you have pictures or texts that
are supporting corroborated evidence of
this affair with Trump she said I've
been advised my by my attorney not to
comment on that and she also admitted
yeah I previously did lie and say I
didn't have an affair with Trump but
that was because I was scared about what
would happen and that last thing which
is listen if you lied before how can we
trust that now you're telling the truth
that came up Anderson Cooper asked her
about it during the 60 Minutes interview
and here's what she had to say how do we
know you're telling the truth
because I have no reason to lie I'm
opening myself up for you know possible
danger and definitely a whole lot of
yeah so I don't know how much we learned
but it's good to continue to get this
stuff on record she is already being
smeared by some on the ride there's a
bunch of articles going around saying
did you notice how dilated starmie
stormy Daniels pupils were even though
she was in a really brightly lit room
which would have caused her pupils to
contract rather than dilate she was
probably on something she was probably
lying we just really can't believe
anything and people seem kind of split
on the importance of this story there's
people who
say this is a lame story there's no
reason to cover it
it's tabloid nonsense and then there's
other who say now this story is
important and there's a couple different
reasons why people are saying the story
is important first is if this is a
pattern and we already have other women
saying hey I also had an affair with
Trump and I ended up either with hush
money or a non-disclosure agreement
maybe with possible threats we've not
yet found out more about that that would
be notable for the President of the
United States to have engaged in that
the more immediate concern is the
legality of that hundred and thirty
thousand dollar payment to stormy
Daniels and whether it was legal because
question one is okay Michael Cohen
Trump's lawyer says he paid stormy a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars out
of his own money if that's true that
could count as an in-kind contribution
to the campaign of Donald Trump of a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars you
might know that the maximum you're
allowed to contribute is twenty seven
hundred dollars so that would be a
problem if Trump's lawyer Michael Cohen
was paid back by Donald Trump for that
money then we have to look at where the
payback money came from because if it
came out of Trump's campaign funds that
could possibly be an illegal use of
campaign money which by the way John
Edwards got in trouble for so there is
precedent in terms of people being
prosecuted for that and lastly there's
the hypocrisy of Trump and I know that
at this point Trump is so hypocritical
on almost every issue I don't know how
much people care about this part of it
but Trump has been complaining for years
and attacking Hillary on the basis of
Bill Clinton's scandals and sexual
impropriety now Trump has the exact same
issues to deal with which I guess were
disqualifying even for Hillary even
though they weren't her scandals I don't
expect that angle to be brought up
really at any point because it's it's so
secondary or tertiary to everything else
going on well I guess the difference
there would be that this was a
consensual relationship where as what
Bill Clinton was accused of was sexual
misconduct that would have been illegal
some of those cases not all some of
those cases not although I I think a bit
more as hypocrisy coming from the event
helices on the right who thought of
Trump as some holy person yes who I
guess believed that his second favorite
book was the Bible after
the book that some other dude wrote and
put Trump's name on we'll see where this
goes I do think that this is a real
story I don't think that this is you
know when we've got the decimation of
the EPA and just all this other stuff
going on obviously this is not the
biggest story but I think it is relevant
and it's important to keep it keep a
sort of tabs on keep track of where the
story is today's program is sponsored in
part by shaker and spoon which is a
monthly cocktail subscription box that
delivers the craft cocktail experience
right to your door sort of like blue
apron but for cocktails every month they
send you the ingredients for three
completely new original cocktail recipes
12 total cocktails enough to last you
the whole month I get tired of having
the same drink all the time because all
I really know my lack of creativity with
cocktails basically means I take soda
water and vodka and then put a piece of
fruit in it that's basically the extent
of my cocktail making skills so I got
what's called the death by gin box from
shaker and spoon three drinks came with
it the ingredients for three drinks the
touristy gimlet the above a persimmon
and the valet these ranged from sweet to
savory including such clever ingredients
as onion brine and I think my favorite
drink was the above a persimmon I'm a
big persimmon guy I've been known to eat
a persimmon or two in my day and the kit
comes with everything you need except
for the gin you pick the gin that you
like I picked a particularly dry gin
which allowed me to for about five
minutes when I had friends over and
explained I was going to be making gin
drinks to kind of sound like I knew what
I was talking about and it's a really
great way to just try different
cocktails instead of relying on memory
or in my case my knowledge of one
cocktail that I know how to make and for
a limited time you can get $20 off by
going to shaker and spoon dot-com slash
Pakman they were watching this on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description under the video